[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> I LET MY LOOK DO THE TALKING.
>> MY BODY IS MY CANVAS, AND MY
CLOTHES IS MY PAINT.
WHEN IT COMES TO FASHION,
THERE'S NO RISK YOU WON'T TAKE.
WELL, CONGRATS ON BEING HOT, BUT
THIS AIN'T FOR YOU.
INTRODUCING FASHION COWARD, THE
ONLY STORE STORE FOR PEOPLE WHO
HATE SHOPPING AND FEEL LOST AND
SCARED, WITH CLOTHES THAT
SUGGEST THE GENERAL IDEA OF A
PERSON.
SO MANY SHIRTS ARE ALMOST
NORMAL, BUT THEN THEY GO LIKE
THIS.
WE KEEP IT SAFE WITH THINGS LIKE
BROWN SWEATER, NAVY SHIRT, PANTS
FOR THE LEGS AND ONE BLACK DRESS
THAT SAYS KEEP IT MOVING.
>> MY STYLE TELLS A STORY.
>> SAME.
MY STORY IS I'M A STRANGER TO
MYSELF.
>> I GO ON CRUISES WITH MY
PARENTS.
>> IDEAL JUROR.
>> CAN'T DECIDE BETWEEN BUTTONS
AND NO BUTTONS?
WE SPLIT THE DIFF WITH A WHOLE
LOT OF THIS.
THAT'S A HALF TRAIL OF BUTTONS
THAT SAY --
>> FAIL.
FAIL, FAIL, FAIL.
>> AND YOU GOT TO TRY ON OUR BIG
GRAY ZIP-UP SWEATSHIRT THAT
DOUBLES AS A REAL LIFE
INVISIBILITY CLOAK.
>> TRY IT ON IN OUR COWARD PROOF
FITTING ROOM.
AS A CHILD, YOU WERE HUMILIATED
IN A KOHL'S FITTING ROOM WHERE
YOUR MOTHER SAID SOMETHING SO
HARMFUL, IT SEARED OFF THE TOP
LAYER OF YOUR BRAIN.
YOU'RE SAFE HERE WITH THINGS
LIKE FAR MIRRORS.
>> THAT'LL DO.
>> IF AN ITEM OF CLOTHING MAKES
YOU ASK, AM I THIS PERSON?
>> MAYBE FOR LIKE A ROOFTOP
PARTY?
>> IT WILL IMMEDIATELY BURST
INTO FLAMES.
DECISIONS ARE HARD.
THAT'S WHY IF YOU TAKE MORE THAN
30 SECONDS TO DECIDE IF YOU WANT
SOMETHING, THE FITTING ROOM
EMITS A MERCY GAS THAT KNOCKS
YOU OUT.
THEN YOU'RE CARRIED HOME BY A
BIG STRONG MAN WHO SHOPS FOR
YOU.
AND WE DON'T SELL SWIMSUITS.
YOU KNOW WHY.
FASHION COWARD.